look at the various states the states
have been handling this you've got a
state like california
which has been locked down it's just
mussolini's
tyranny over there locked down more than
virtually any other state
they're not doing any better on covid
than florida which has been open
basically from the beginning like quite
open
new york has been extremely locked down
new york has done worse than any other
state on covid
that's why andy cuomo has to answer
questions about some ridiculous sex
scandal right now
not because of the sex scandals because
of covid so
at least one reporter asks joe biden
this is again it's not a press
conference it's just sort of at the very
end they
try to shout a few questions to biden
ask biden
hey mr president
florida's looking pretty good seems to
disprove all your stupid covid theories
what do you have to say about that joe
biden does not mince words
i hope everybody's realized by now these
masks make a difference
we are on the cusp of being able to
fundamentally
change the nature of this disease
because the way in which we're able to
get vaccines in people's
arms we've been able to move that all
the way up to the end of may to have
enough for every american
to get every adult american to get a
shot
and the last thing the last thing we
need is neanderthal thinking that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask forget it
it still matters now
joe biden using this phrase neanderthal
thinking
actually carries quite a bit of weight
because joe biden remembers the
neanderthals you know when joe biden was
growing up in delaware
uh i forget during which uh era of the
earth's history
uh he knew and a lot of neanderthals
they were wandering around
then you know very sadly they went
extinct and
uh now we we live in this world without
them but he remembers what it was like
and he he doesn't want to go back to
that neanderthal thinking
so i just in my mind i've got to compare
two guys
ron desantis in florida kept the state
open
everybody's happy everybody's free virus
very well contained
andrew cuomo in new york
uh not doing great lock down the state
and killed a bunch of senior citizens
and took away his constituents liberties
and rights
if i'm and i'm just saying i don't even
want you to think ideologically here i
just want you to think as a purely
physical matter which of those guys
looks and sounds more like a neanderthal
is it ron desantis very articulate guy
you know he's
relatively handsome or is it
andrew cuomo andrew cuomo with the
looks just like a bulldog i think it's
probably probably going to be the latter
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]